if you want to help us with our big
crowd funding campaign but you're not
able to donate with dollars that's ok we
have a referral contest IndieGoGo has
this great thing where if you use the
Facebook and Twitter buttons on the
campaign page right uh we can track the
donations that come in based on your
referrals the top 5 refers to our
campaign who refer the the largest
number of donors will get the complete
package perk for free this is the two
hundred ninety nine dollar perk which
includes a signed 2017 david pakman show
calendar a david pakman show t-shirt
made from one hundred percent recycled
materials and to david pakman show
bumper stickers that is a two hundred
ninety nine dollar perk but if you wanna
refer donors to the campaign the top
five referrers are going to get the two
hundred ninety nine dollar perk for free
we will even ship it to you wherever you
are in the world at no cost hopefully
you're in the US cuz shipping as much
cheaper but hey if you're in Singapore
like some of our audiences you're in
Hong Kong like some of our audiences we
will ship it there use the Facebook and
Twitter buttons on the IndieGoGo
campaign page to share the campaign and
the top five referrers will get the two
hundred ninety nine dollar perk for free